films will be required to meet new
inclusion standards to be eligible for
the Academy Awards for Best Picture
they'll have to have a certain
percentage of actors or crew from
underrepresented racial and ethnic
groups what do you think of these new
inclusion standards for films they make
me vomit no one should be telling me as
an artist
that I have to give in to the latest
most current idea of what morality is
and what are we risking are we really
risking hurting people's feelings you
can't legislate that are we crazy do we
not know that art is Art this is so
patronizing it's so it's so Thoughtless
and and and treating people like
children